monsieur moriarty monsieur moriarty
je n'ai jamais eu cette impression
d'être fait pour quelque chose de grand
quelque chose qui te dépasse je les dis
à personne je garde ça secret mavericks
existe mavericks c'est peut-être la plus
grosse vague du monde
je prends de cette vague cette vague est
un mythe tous les quatre ans surfent là
bas et on veut que ça perdure
entre les mois dans ce cas de toute
façon il ira la chercher l'âme au péril
de sa vie
tu vas pas pareil quand cette vague
déferle uniquement bar forte houle de
nord-ouest et la fenêtre météo et dans
deux semaines il te reste douze semaines
d'accord d'abord une ou deux règles
avant de commencer la première tune
abîmera point la voiture de ton voisin
désolé monsieur
s'appelle le cimetière l'espal courante
embarqué ici tu serais mis en pièces
doit pouvoir rester au moins quatre
minutes en apnée c'est impossible
ça va tout changer si vous vous trompez
et si j'ai raison
il ne s'agit pas que le surf
il s'agit d'assumer ses choix dans la
vie
de trouver cette chose unique
je te rend libre